- On this episode, I have my dad join me.
(hip hop music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is The #AskGaryVee Show
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode--
- [Andy] 118.
- 118 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
So as you can see, this is a
very, this is my father, Sasha.
A lot of you don't know my dad.
I love my dad very, very much.
My dad is an immigrant from
the former Soviet Union
who I'm very fond of.
Many of you who have crossed
over from Wine Library TV
to the #AskGaryVee Show
know this character.
Many of you are about
to have some fun times.
As you can see, we have a
lot of food and wine here.
We just taped seven, six or seven videos
that will run in Wine Library where my dad
is the founder, CEO, and owner of.
Staphon, Andy K, and DRock are here,
we played four or five
hours of basketball.
I'm actually on family vacation right now.
I'm supposed to be off--
- It's a tradition.
- Yeah, we do it every year.
- Every year.
- I'm supposed to be off the grid,
but we decided to tape some wine videos
and I've been missing the show.
I know I've been traveling
a lot, I know I come back.
Are we getting on in on Monday?
- [DRock] I think so, yeah.
- I think we're gonna
sneak one in on Monday
but again on the West Coast.
India, unfortunately, is not
here so Andy, let me get up.
DRock, you're gonna have
to roll with me here.
Andy, who, Andy, you haven't
really been on the show.
Andy who is a big part of our team.
Does all the paid acquisition.
A lot of you who
discovered me on Facebook,
it's because Andy and I, but really Andy,
have been strategic about
finding you in your Facebook feed
so Andy, let's get into--
- The show.
- The show, I tricked you,
saw what happened there?
- You tricked me, yeah, it was good.
- [Sasha] Why, Andy made Gary famous?
- No, Andy did not make me famous.
I made Andy famous.
Alright, you made me famous, Dad.
- Oh, I see.
- Alright, let's get into the show, Andy.
- [Voiceover] Melanie asks,
"You've led WineLibrary
"and VaynerMedia through
insane growth, what's your
"best advice to those
leading growing teams?"
- You know, I think one of
the things that I think about
when growing, and you know,
Wine Library probably,
from 1998 dad, until
2004 or five, in kind of,
that five or six, seven year period,
we probably went from what,
how many employees do you
think, with Dick and Bob,
maybe 10 or twelve to like
eighty or ninety, right?
Would you say in that
five or six year period?
- Yeah.
- So--
- But we were overstaffed.
- Yes, dad.
- No, no, no but we were
overstaffed for a reason.
- Yeah, we were growing!
- We were growing
- And the same thing's happening now.
I'm sure AJ would now
say we're overstaffed
because we've gone from
thirty to 525 people
in the last three years at VaynerMedia.
I think the big thing for
me, and it's interesting
it's fun to have my dad here.
The big thing with me that I think
is a little bit different
than my dad and AJ,
I'm just, I'm kind of,
when you're going through insane growth,
I definitely don't worry
about the little things.
You gotta move fast.
There's going to be a ton of headaches.
There's going to always be issues,
but I try to focus on the top line, right.
When you're trying to grow quickly,
you're really growing top line revenue.
A lot of times that may be at the mercy
of gross profit and net profit.
For sure there's always
issues with personnel,
there's always disagreements
and things of that nature,
but for me, it's not
sweating the small things.
To me, I keep my heads
very much in the cloud.
I really focus on the agenda at hand,
and I think where most people struggle,
is they focus on the small things.
They get caught up in the things
that may not matter as much
in a net net game, and
I think that has been
a very major factor in my business success
that I'm able to not get caught up
in the things that I think
the far majority of people
get caught up in.
I think people get emotional about things,
I think people don't
project financial outcomes,
you know, both when I got
involved in my dad's business
and with VaynerMedia,
the growth of the revenue
on the high end, on the top
line, was very extreme and
I think that's something that
people struggle to calibrate.
To me it's not sweating the small things.
Dad?
- Yeah.
- Great, let's get into the next question.
- I think that's well, well, yeah.
- Right?
- You know, look, a lot of
people now watch the show.
The show's gotten very big,
I don't know if you know.
- No, I didn't know.
- Ask #GaryVeeShow, it's very big.
- So how come I'm the
first time on the show?
- Well, I mean, it's all
just worked out, timing.
You're very busy, you're busy.
You don't come to New York
when I'm taping the show.
- Right, that's true.
- Tolls, it got too expensive.
- You have a very different point of view,
you have a very unique point of view on me
that the audience does not have.
- Listen, no question about
it, not because he's my son
he's a very, very special kid, no doubt.
- I'm almost 40, Dad.
- You're always going to be a kid to me.
- I know, I know.
- Please.
- I get it, I get it.
- You're children will be--
- Why don't you tell the
audience when you first realized
how special I was.
(laughter)
- Oh I knew what--
- No, tell them, this will be fun for me.
- Shit
- I can't get you to tell me to my face.
- No, no!
- I always give you the
credit where the credit--
- Always.
- Okay, what, I'm going
to tell you to your face?
No, no, no, you sold drapery right?
- Ha, you're going way back.
- Wait a minute.
- I was 10.
- What year was that?
- 1985.
- No, before, was (mumbles).
- Yeah 1985, I was 10, when
I did the mini flea market.
- Mini, Andy, Mini flea market.
- '85.
- They had some--
- (mumbles) clock.
- No, no.
- A drapery.
A blue drapery.
- And my day at that time, I used to take
Sunday off once and a while
to spend quality time
with my children, right?
- Which meant we would sleep.
- Listen, I used to work
16 hour days, 14 hour days.
- For sure.
- That's not so easy.
- Nope.
- But, Mom gave you the draperies, right?
- Yeah.
- And you sold it.
- And they were stunned.
- Yeah.
- And Grandma.
- And yeah, listen, I knew it.
You're my son, right?
When I lent you, supposedly,
no I did lend you--
- You lended me, yep.
- Money, a thousand dollars.
- You lended me a thousand dollars
to start my baseball card
business when I was 14.
- I was in the business, right?
And a couple people said to
me, you know, you're an idiot.
You're never going to see this money back.
- I paid you back fast.
- Fast.
- Within the month.
- And that was hard, that was like 1989
when I could only go to a
show once every other weekend.
- And then you start working in a store.
- Kenwood Chardonnay.
- No, Sebastiani.
- Well, that I asked you to move.
- Yeah, well.
- Kenwood, I sold.
- And that's uh, yeah.
- Alright, let's go Andy.
- Okay, let's go.
- [Voiceover] Buzz.hr asks, I
started a daily vlog series.
Should I focus on Youtube,
Facebook video, or both?
- Buzzer, this is interesting.
We're in a very interesting
time with now with Youtube--
- That's his name?
- That's a name, Dad.
But it's probably a screen name.
Buzzer, it's a very
interesting time right now.
I think Youtube and
Facebook Video are both
the two dominant platforms.
But I think six or seven months ago,
DRock, we okay with the sound?
I know it's windy.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- We'll just go with it.
I think that.
By the way, I am so pumped.
The #AskGaryVee Show
audience is not ready
for all this craziness.
- No?
- I think, show AJ, show AJ real quick.
Let's say hi to AJ.
Aj's got his drone.
- [AJ] I've got problems with the drone.
- [Gary] The drone's broken?
- [AJ] I want DRock.
I need DRock's help.
- [Gary] Alright, we're almost done.
We're doing a quick
#AskGaryVee episode with Dad.
- [AJ] Real quick.
- Go ahead.
- [AJ] It says the controller's
disconnected to the camera?
Do you think it's because
we turned on the app
before we synced the two, like.
- [DRock] And you turned it
off and turned it back on?
- [AJ] Yeah, we tried a lot of that.
- Alright DRock let's bang this out.
This is black and white right now, AJ.
- [AJ] I know.
- [D-Rock] That's fine.
- There's gonna be a lot of
black and white in this episode.
- [DRock] First thing.
- [AJ] First thing.
- Buzz, I think that Facebook Video
is grossly underestimated,
I think that YouTube's obviously
the established leader,
but I think Facebook's incredible
Andy and I have been
doing enormous amounts
of testing on audiences.
Right now we're running a ton.
So many of you have watched the USC video
if you haven't, watch it here.
Link it up, over my dad's face.
- [DRock] Yep.
- And so, I think it's
incredibly effective.
There's nothing like Facebook targeting.
And I think, both, the answer's both.
I think both really matter.
I can say that, you know,
eating our own dog food,
Andy, we're really focusing
on Facebook right now.
We have an understanding
of what YouTube's all about
but the targeting is just
incredible on Facebook.
So the answer's both, brother.
Focus on both.
Let's move on.
- [Voiceover] John asks,
"What's one question
"you get asked all the time
that you can't stand answering?"
- What's one question I
get asked all the time
that I don't, that I
can't stand answering?
Which one is that Dad?
The Valdez?
Great Pinot, right?
- And I'm not, you know?
- I know you're not a big Pinot guy.
Alright DRock, over here.
This is not a wine show.
- I think I'm going to finish it.
- You can finish it.
- I don't know if there's
any question that bothers me
that people--
- He's so chill.
(laughter)
Nothing, nothing, you know.
Really, doesn't take it personally, uh.
- [Andy] What's a question
you always get asked--
- You know, Dad, I'm gonna take
advantage of having you here
you know, obviously we're the
same but we're very different.
- But you've got a lot of me.
- Yes, I know.
- The better--
- The competitive thing.
- Yeah.
- But, were you interested in the fact
that I'm so unphased?
You, listen, there's a
lot of people watching.
Tell the truth, you get upset.
- Eh, about?
- A lot of things.
(laughter)
- Uh, yes of course.
I'm human, I have yeah.
- But, you agree, in
business I'm kind of weird.
I go into this weird state where I'm not--
- He's different and he's very different.
No no no, I have to hand it to him
not because he's sitting here,
and I really want to give
him compliments, you know,
while he's here.
- Guys, just so you know, I'm fishing here
because I don't get this so I'm
using advantage of the show.
- But he's very different here.
He made a statement, and I
can't even repeat the statement,
because, to me it's against my religion--
- (laughs) I don't even know.
- He will do business with--
- Anybody.
Hitler?
- You know it rubs me the wrong way,
but it's true, its been proven fact.
And I'm a principled guy.
- I'm a principled guy!
- You are, but, you put
what's good for the business
before your own--
- My own feelings.
- Yeah, and I can't, and
I'm exactly reversed.
You know, I'm, I don't know.
And probably that's
what was holding me back
listen, I'm not complaining,
I did pretty okay--
- Yes you did, mister.
- With no language, no, you know.
- 100 bucks, poor.
- Yeah, I can write a book and my book
would be better than his,
but that's beside the point.
(laughter)
He's making a face.
- Because it wouldn't be better.
That's why I'm making a face.
Let's play one on one.
Show the basket.
We're gonna play one
on one to settle this.
- Listen, we just had my
younger son get married.
- AJ, they know AJ.
- Everybody knows him.
And you would not believe what
took place at the wedding.
Gary gave a speech, I gave a speech.
My daughter jumped in, and it became--
- We're a very competitive family.
- Yeah, it's healthy.
- Slightly unhealthy, but
I'm pumped we're unhealthy.
- What do you mean unhealthy?
- Well, we're very--
- End of the day--
- We love each other.
- Even in the business, never left upset.
- What, within a year?
(laughter)
We never left upset in a day?
- We kiss each other--
- Well we love each other, yeah.
So, I don't remember the question.
But I think ultimately,
Andy, there's no question
that really bothers me.
I think most people know the
answer to most of the questions
that they ask me,
I just don't think they
want to put in the work.
And one thing that, I will say this.
I think one of the best
days of my life, my life,
the life that I've lived,
almost 40 years now,
was when, you know it's funny,
as great a day of my life,
I don't fully remember
it, but I do remember
several months ago, maybe within the year,
maybe within 18 months,
you kind of telling me,
"Man, for as hard as I
work, you work really hard."
- (scoffs) Honestly, I felt at
the time, I was working hard.
Sundays away, 14 hours, all this shit.
This one, but thank God for his wife.
I have to say this.
Not every woman would--
- (laughs) It's true.
- He travels half a year.
- These guys know.
- And these guy know.
- Lizzie's the best.
- Yeah--
- That's why these weeks are best
- I love her, I mean.
As a matter of fact, I just discussed
with your mom another
day about your situation.
Not every woman would, you know--
- Listen, it's intense.
- Yeah.
- We're going for it.
- But you have a dream, like I had.
When I came to this country,
I never going to forget.
And listen, I don't to tell my story--
- No, listen, let's do it, let's do it.
- I came in 1978, and
I remember I landed in JFK
Pan Am, is that the name?
- Pan Am.
- Pan Am, there I land.
- Out of business, mismanaged.
- Yeah, I was walking
on Quinn's boulevard.
- I know the story, go ahead.
You tell them, not me.
- And right there I saw a
sign, it said Alexander's.
- Which was a department store,
for some of you old timers.
- My actual official name was Alexander.
Everybody called me Sasha, whatever.
And I looked, my cousin who was already
a year in this country, right?
And we walked by it, and the
whole family was together,
And I looked, and I said, you know,
someday I'm going to have that.
And she looked at me and she,
you know like, "Come on."
Not exactly the same.
- Wine Library's very similar to that.
- Yeah, so, it's, you have to have.
But of course, he got bigger dream.
- Well that's the way it's supposed to be.
- Absolutely.
To own Jets, I'm looking for
a couple of points there.
- You wanna own a couple of jets there?
(laughter)
- Alright Andy, let's keep going.
- [Voiceover] Angie asks,
"Successful leaders say
"you're the sum of the five people
"you spend the most time with.
"How do you level up your five?"
- This is an interesting question.
This is something I've spent a lot of time
trying to figure out.
Do I, am I willing to surround myself
with people who are better than me,
I know it's windy, DRock,
relax, we're outside.
I know, a lot of times
I've wondered if I'm
surrounding myself with
people that are not.
You know, I'm very nurturing.
I like having a lot of people around me,
I like building up people.
- True.
- Yeah, I like it.
- Very true.
Listen, not because he's my son.
I don't want to sit and
brag on in front of him.
He's extremely, extremely special kid.
If I knew what I'm going
to get, it's a true story
by the way, his mother
before we got married,
said she has this thing,
she wants to have five kids.
And of course, being a young
guy I say, hey, no problem.
- (laughs) My parents were married at 20.
- Right, we were young.
And the time went on, I
got scared about education,
to be able to pay, the
kids should not have loans,
such nonsense, they should all have loans.
- I would have paid it off easy.
- Right, and so, he's,
again I'm not going to
sit and brag about you--
- I think I might have you
on the show more often.
This is, I'm feeling nice.
- I'm being very honest with you,
maybe somebody out there
who's going to stumble
on this video, whatever.
His DNA should be bottled.
I'm very serious, not
because we had four wines.
Well, that helps, but,
I mean, he's extremely,
extremely special in many ways.
And Barack Obama doesn't
invite him to the White House.
- Please, this is nice enough,
you don't have to get crazy.
- Just because,
as a father I'm very proud.
In the business, we had
a lot of disagreements.
(laughter)
- We could disagree about the
color of the goddamn thing.
But end of the day, we
bounce off each other things.
And I don't think Gary
ever mentions that because
he's a very competitive guy.
But a lot of good ideas,
and I don't want to put
myself somewhere, but a
lot of them beginning,
was Wine Library, it came
driving an hour each way
- I wrote a Medium--
- I miss it so much.
I miss it so much.
And I understand, listen,
he's got things going on,
but that part I always miss because
it was very special.
You know even today when
the family get together,
it's, even my daughter's
birthday was a couple days ago,
you know she turned what, 30?
- Six.
- Right.
- Sorry Liz.
- Yeah, no but even her
friends saw the dynamic
of our family, and I
have to give it to mom.
Mom built a very strong foundation.
Who grew up without a mother, you know.
She was at age five, she lost her mother,
and but she's very special person
who built this family, and you know,
I work and she was building the family.
It's a great combination,
and it's you know
I'm very proud what this
family were able to accomplish,
and especially what Gary and AJ.
I mean you know, special kids definitely.
All of them, and I see grandchildren,
Oliver and you know.
- Alexander.
- Alexander is eating a lot of olives,
so we decided to name him Olive.
- He wants to call himself Olive.
And that's a really real
special, real special.
- Thanks dad, I have no idea
Andy what the question was.
But, what was it again?
- [Voiceover] Sum of the five
people you spend the most time with?
- Yeah I mean, I think
that, yeah I think I have.
I definitely over the
last five to seven years
surround myself with
higher caliber characters.
I think it's a commitment, I think,
but on the flip-side, I'm
very comfortable in bringing
value to the people
that maybe aren't better
than me, I think giving
back is massively important.
I think it's, there's a level of karma,
and I think as long as you're focused on
surrounding yourself with five people
that can bring your level up,
I think the real answer is
it's about 10, right, I think it's about
creating a scenario where
you have five people
that are leveling you up,
and I think it's about
surrounding yourself with five people
that you level up, and I think
I think I get tremendous enjoyment on
leveling up the five people around me.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks,
"I got a question for ya.
"How bad do you wish Tom
Brady was your quarterback?"
- What is this again?
- The question is how bad do I want
Tom Brady to be my quarterback?
- You don't.
- I'll take him, I mean look.
Brett Favre was probably
one of the five players
I disliked the most in the NFL,
but I've said it before on the show,
the second that a player takes on my logo,
they're alright, right?
- That's true.
- Wayne Gretzky we didn't like, I liked,
well my dad's a Devils
fan, I'm a Rangers fan,
but I think, you know
he's getting a little old.
I think he's, listen, I would cut my,
I'm going to say this,
I would cut my entire
right arm off, I would, sit calm,
I would cut my entire right,
left arm off for Aaron Rodgers
because I think we would
win the Super Bowl.
I think Aaron Rodgers is the best quarter
well Andrew Luck, I would
cut my entire left arm off
for Andrew Luck, I'm going Indianapolis
for week two.
- What about Dan Marino?
- Dan Marino's finished.
- Right.
- Thank God, those were tough years.
The Jets have really
struggled, I mean we had
Dan Marino, Jim Kelly, and Tom Brady,
We've had basically all
the three other teams
in our division, show Little AJ.
AJ's very upset, he's
never won a championship.
AJ's never won a championship, AJ's 28
alright (mumbles), he's done, he's 28
he's never won a championship,
because my baseball
team and hockey team won
before he was old enough to enjoy it.
So he's a Knicks and Jets fan.
AJ, would you cut your left
arm off for Andrew Luck?
- Smart, smart.
- AJ says no, I would.
- [AJ] You wouldn't either.
- I would, I'd cut my
left pinky off for sure.
Would you cut your left pinky off?
- No.
- I would, I would 100%.
- What is he cut?
- JPP.
- Giants right?
- Yeah because he's--
- What's going on with his dog.
- He lost his index finger,
alright let's move on.
Move on, last question,
AJ's calling for time,
we've gotta wrap up the show.
- Where are we going?
- We have to eat dinner with the family.
That's it, oh that was it, dad.
- That's it?
- That's it dad, dad as my special guest,
you get to ask the question of the day.
Any question you want, please don't make
it political like you
did on Wine Library.
- You know what, I have to say something.
- That's not a question.
- No but I want to say it.
And you were young,
again, I mean this kid is
like I said, special kid, when
the Soviet Union fell apart.
- Oh that's a good one.
- How old you were, 91 right, 90.
- Yeah I was 15 I think.
- He walked into the room and you know--
- It was obviously a
big day for our family,
because you know we were born there
- And he said what the
worst thing could happen.
And I look at him and I was like,
meaning I'm not as smart as my son,
but he still have my DNA, he said dad
it's the worst thing, I said why?
He said it's going to be
unbalanced in the world.
Meaning, two superpower countries,
everything was equal, and you know what,
years later, I said, he
was absolutely right.
- it's good to have balance.
- All the craziness that's
going on today in the world,
because it's unbalanced, if we
still have Soviet Union here.
Cold War basically, and America here.
All this bullshit with all this--
- Alright calm down,
calm down no politics.
- No politics nothing would happen.
Nobody would throw bombs.
- Things would happen,
things would happen.
- No, absolutely not, pre-that.
- It's supposed to be a question, dad.
- So what is the question?
- Well you're supposed
to ask the question.
- I do?
- Yeah, and then people answer.
- And people answer.
Maybe like a Jets thing, a wine thing,
maybe your favorite wine,
maybe keep a little chill,
and not geo-political intensity.
- Who's more charismatic, my son or me?
- Jesus, they're gonna
love you for asking this.
You're gonna get more
votes than you deserve.
(laughter)
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(laughter)
(hip-hop music)